oh this one's been a long time coming
[Music]
so
I'm gonna kind of vent
um not too angrily because like
I am frustrated but I'm not mad
I get why the thing I'm about to go off
on happens and I'll talk about that but
I need to talk about a frequent
disconnect that often happens between a
criticism I will have of a piece of
media of any kind and the response I get
in the comments and this isn't as Bare
Bones as people don't agree with my
opinion like fine don't agree with my
opinion as long as you're not rude and
call me transphobic names like whatever
I
you have your opinion I have mine what
drives me crazy though is I will bring
up something in a movie TV show video
game book whatever
and what I'm talking about and what I'm
complaining about what I'm critiquing or
what I'm questioning is structural
and then people will try and respond to
that criticism
by giving me a narrative answer
I will eventually get to the specific or
recent thing that made me decide you
know what I'm just going to make a video
on this but it's a semi-recent film and
that's a little more spoilery so I'll
get to that in a little bit but I can
tell you this is something that's been
happening
for years
the first time I remember noticing this
disconnect between my criticism and the
reactions to it was way back
with Batman v Superman dawn of Justice
when a lot of the things that I didn't
like about the movie and like I don't
like them like opinions are very divided
about that movie even at the time
because there were people who liked it
immediately down the line there would be
people who defend the director's cup but
not the theatrical
I don't like it and and my issues I
can't imagine would be uh excessively
fixed by the director's cut and I
disliked the original enough that like I
just don't wanna but we're not talking
about the director's cut specifically in
that but when I made complaints about
for example
how convoluted a Lex Luthor's plan was
what I was complaining about was I did
not understand why a writer would
construct this plan in this way why you
would have a character make these
choices
because it didn't make any sense to me
from a writing perspective to have the
plan be this convoluted especially with
a movie that has so much else on its
plate
but I got an awful lot of response in
the comments laying out the specifics of
what Lex was doing and why he did it
that wasn't what I was complaining about
I wasn't complaining about the
characters choices I was complaining
about the writer's choices
and this is something that can come up
as I said semi-regularly where I will
get frustrated or and generally this
comes up with things that I criticize as
opposed to things I praise but generally
it's not uncommon for me to have a
criticism that has to do with the
writing the structure and the decisions
of the creators
and then I'll get a response in the
comments citing an in-universe reason
for why the characters did something
my beef is not with the characters
so if you want the uh hoity-toity
academic version of this we're talking
about doylest and watsonian perspectives
now uh the doylest perspective has to do
with what was the writer doing why did
the writer do what they did the
watsonian perspective is in universe and
is why did the characters
do what they did now to be frank one
does inform the other the doilus
explanation of why a writer decides to
do something will inform the choices
that the characters in universe will
then make in order to justify whatever
the doylest answer was so for example to
go with one from Arthur Conan Doyle
which is yes where these terms come from
he at one point killed off Sherlock
Holmes his most popular character
and then later on he brought Sherlock
Holmes back
now the doylest answer for why he did
that was that fans were clamoring for it
and he was not making as much money off
of his other writings so he brought the
character back but he also needed to
come up with the watsonian reason as to
why the character back to be explained
to the audience in Universe by Watson
because keep in mind that those original
Sherlock Holmes stories were actually
narrated by Watson he's the POV
character so Watson explains the in
Universe reason to cover for Arthur
Conan Doyle's real life reason now that
particular break uh deals with the first
sort of way in which these things can
sometimes clash and it's the least
interesting way that they can Clash so
I'll get this one out of the way which
is sometimes there is no good watsonian
answer in the doylest answer will just
cover you now you're not required as a
viewer to take all things into account
but you know if you find yourself
watching a TV show for example and stuff
is going down that it really feels like
there's a character who should be
involved in this or should you know jump
in and take part in this but they're not
there and you can't come up with a good
in-universe reason like they haven't
been captured they're not missing
they're just not here why aren't they
here this feels important this feels
like they should be there well if you
can't come up with a good watsonian
reason maybe just accept the doilist one
that the actor wasn't filming that week
they took a week off
yeah now
part of doing writing well is creating
watsonian explanations to cover for your
doyless choices and some writers just
fail to do that at all but that's not
really what I want to talk about here
because
when someone like me or anyone makes a
criticism of a writer's choice
trying to respond to it with a watsonian
answer of why in Universe the characters
would have done what they did
is literally ignoring what the issue
brought up was
and it's a very special kind of
frustrating
and I will now lay out specifically the
example that made me want to finally sit
down and talk about this flat out and
this comes from Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. if you have not seen that movie
yet and you don't want to get spoiled
jump to the following time code and
we'll move past it for everyone else who
has already seen it
um or just wants to know the context and
doesn't care here we go there is a point
about between midway and two-thirds into
the movie where the villain the high
evolutionary destroys an entire planet
and that really ticked me off and I
mentioned this in my review now the
reason it ticked me off was because I
felt like I was seeing the hand of the
author
because I was trying to figure out why
did James Gunn decide to do that what
was he trying to accomplish
because it didn't tell us anything new
about the villain the high evolutionary
we already knew what kind of cruel he
was scaling it up to planetary sizes not
really new information that's something
we just could have assumed as it stands
so it's not providing us with that
as to the
presumably billions of living creatures
who have now been wiped out it's okay to
have cannon fodder let me be clear but
James Gunn did just enough
characterizing and just enough
establishing of who it was who lived on
this planet these sort of animal beings
you might have seen them in one of the
trailers who are living in you know a
very sort of 1980 Suburban existence we
see them we see how they are living we
see and establish their children there
are families there is love here
and they all get wiped out
now these characters are not
characterized enough that it's going to
have a full meaningful
um impact on the audience I mean it had
one on me but in a bad way because like
we're not invested in these people but
it's just enough characterization
that we it does feel very strange
that they carry no narrative weight
there's basically one line of dialogue
after this entire planet gets destroyed
where a character says what kind of
madman destroys an entire planet and
then they move on this has no material
impact on any of the characters nor does
it tell us anything new about the
villain and because it is failing to
provide any of these things nor is it
providing a particularly meaningful
catharsis as an event unto itself
it made me upset at James Gunn because
at this point I personally have gotten
increasingly touchy about needlessly
cruel deaths and this felt cruel because
if they just hadn't characterized these
animals at all I probably wouldn't care
too much
but if he had also by contrast given
proper narrative weight and had this
really deeply emotional impact somebody
who is an established character maybe
but neither of those things happen and
so to me the wiping out of this planet
these people these families that you
went out of your way to establish exist
is just cruel
and I'm at a point in my life where I
don't do well with cruelty so in my
review I was questioning why would you
do that
and multiple people came in the comments
to give me the explanation of why the
character of the high evolutionary did
that
my criticism was not of the character it
was of the writer
now I do understand a big part of why
this happens and this is actually kind
of inherent to the nature of being I
guess I'll call myself a Critic
according to Rotten Tomatoes I am so why
not so this is kind of part of being a
Critic I am literally watching movies
and television differently from most of
you and I don't just mean the obvious
having different different points of
cultural reference different preferences
and whatnot I'm not even talking about
that I'm just talking about the fact
that when you do this for long enough
when you have gotten to the point where
you are expecting to give your thoughts
and opinions on a piece of media that
you have taken in
you can't get away with just saying I
liked it I didn't like it first of all
reviews Too Short second of all
especially for me and my way of viewing
criticism if people don't understand why
you do or don't like it then that that
that opinion of I liked it or I didn't
it's kind of meaningless unless they
share basically your exact opinions
broadly speaking
because I like to think that when I
explain why I do or don't like something
by explaining why oh like it's because
of this or how this is used or did you
know was this particular element then
even people who don't necessarily agree
can still get some value out of that
because they can go okay well she she
said she had a problem with this because
of her dislike for this Trope I don't
really have a problem with that Trope
though so that may not be a problem for
me in this movie even though it was a
problem for her so getting used to
providing explanations providing ground
providing critique like not just opinion
but actual critique gets you to start
viewing things differently
and you start to think about your
opinion and why it's there now I can't
say this is how all critics do it but
generally speaking I'll come out of a
piece of media and start with my broad
overall feeling like I feel
this way generally positive generally
negative extremely positive extremely
negative whatever that may be and then
figure out the ins and outs of why the
film or TV show or whatever left me
feeling that way I examined my own
opinion so that I can provide a critique
with context so that you understand
where my opinion comes from
but no matter how well I do or don't
explain it it does mean that
fundamentally I am watching these things
differently and I feel that a big part
of the Divide when this sort of thing
comes up for me is that I am providing
an explanation that has to do with my
perspective not only as a critic but as
a writer and I'll come back to that in a
second
but I'm getting responses from people
who took it in strictly as a viewer and
that is like let me be clear I'm not
trying to get on a high horse I'm not
saying that looking at something through
the lens of criticism and critique that
is the superior way to experience art
like no it's not it just happens to be
what I do for a living
it's not an inherently better way but it
does mean that sometimes people will
engage with a piece of art just as a
piece of entertainment then they'll feel
what they feel and they don't
necessarily need or want to fully
examine all the meanings behind that
they don't have to they're not obligated
and honestly a lot of them are probably
happier with a lot of the entertainment
they take in than I am
criticism you know can really eat away
at your enjoyment if you're not careful
but then there's the other thing that I
just mentioned there's the fact that I'm
also a writer I have been trying to
actively engage in some manner of
creative writing that wasn't just
assigned to me as a school project since
middle school and I've never stopped
I care a lot about the nature of writing
and the kind of choices that a writer
makes and again I want to be clear this
doesn't mean that I am better equipped
to talk about this I'm just explaining
my headspace because to me I actually
get pretty invested in why did a writer
make that choice I actually tend to get
more invested in that than why a
character made a choice or at least if
it's something that feels off I get more
invested in it because honestly if a
piece of media fully absorbs my
attention
then I am way more interested in what
the characters are doing but if
something has happened that has pulled
me out of that I start really examining
well what's the writer doing
and
as I said I can't stop myself from doing
that I've always found this fascinating
I can tell you that back when I used to
listen to audio commentaries on movies
which I haven't done in years partially
because I don't have a lot of time to do
it anymore and also partially because
they've gotten bad that happened uh like
15 20 years ago or so and I could even
go off on exactly why they started to
deeply suck but that would be too much
of a tangent for even me so I'm going to
set that aside but I will say that the
most interesting audio tracks that I
ever listened to on movies involved the
writing and that aspect of the creation
either from writer directors or
occasionally rarely but occasionally
you'd get an audio commentary track from
the actual screenwriters those were
always my favorite because you know the
way they chose to shot on the day how
difficult the stunt was how many takes
they took you know what alternate takes
the actor did the director you know you
know how we set up this shot
that's not really what interests me
ultimately what interests me at the end
of the day is storytelling and the
choices made in telling a story as a
narrative
and so I always like my favorite
commentary tracks the ones that I would
listen to more than once were pretty
much all in some way tied to the writers
because that's the part that I just I
zero in on I can't help it I always do
and my interest in why writers do or
don't do what they do you know informs
my own work whether it's my book my play
multiple short stories that you can't
find so don't ask but regardless even if
you think I'm a bad writer
which you're entitled to your opinion
um regardless of that that's still the
lens through which I view this stuff
I can get hung up on good or bad special
effects camera Works don't work like if
it's exceptionally good or exceptionally
bad yeah I'll notice and probably
comment on it but broadly speaking what
I'm going to talk about most of the time
is just the story itself because that's
just where my head goes so when
something irks me in a why did the
writer decide to do that way
and I try my best and maybe I don't
always communicate it well
thus I'm now making this video which
will go who knows how long
um when I critique something that's
about
what the writer chose to do
getting an answer about the characters
is just frustrating because I feel
unheard
it's it's a kind of frustration that
comes like it's like if you took your
car into the mechanics
you said okay well you know the engine's
rattling a little bit and the brakes are
kind of are starting to squeal a little
bit when they get applied and the
mechanic looks at your car and goes
you know that you know what it is
the car is blue and there's some bird
crap on your window
okay
um those things are both true those are
accurate statements but they're not what
I'm talking about
and that's that's just the way that it
can often feel sometimes and also it's
the kind of thing that can really Drive
High degrees of frustration
because
just being disappointed in a story as a
narrative
that's not fun
but I don't really get worked up about
that I mean it's I think it's probably a
big part of why I came out of
um the rise of Skywalker and went that
was fine I guess
because I understood why every decision
was made a lot of them were bad
decisions but I wasn't
um I wasn't confounded by it that's the
thing you know what tends to rile me up
when I can't figure out what a writer is
doing or why this is why the Doctor Who
episodes hell bent and the Timeless
children
infuriate me so much not just because I
feel that they are bad stories just
narratively and aren't fulfilling or at
the very least they aren't for me but
what truly confounds me and the reason
why when I've gone off on those episodes
I've really gone off on those episodes
is because in both cases I'm not
entirely sure I understand what it was
that Stephen Moffitt and Christiana
respectively were trying to do as
writers
and to what extent I think I might have
an inclination as to what they were
trying to do I don't understand why you
would do what they did in order to try
to accomplish that
and so it's that confusion
and hellbent is another one that this
kind of thing happened to me
because I would say things that
basically amount to do I don't get what
Moffitt is doing with this and people
will come in with explanations as to why
the doctor made this decision my
criticism isn't off the doctor
it's of the writer because I don't get
what he's doing and to what extent I
think maybe he's trying to do something
it doesn't make sense that he do it in
the way that he did which is why I feel
like I don't get I know what he's doing
because if it is what it seems like then
why would you do it like that
and you can hear even talking in the
abstract I get a little worked up
talking about that
and
it's never going to stop happening
because like I said fundamentally I
watch things differently even if I
wasn't a critic that would be true to a
certain extent because as I said I've
never stopped trying to be a writer well
I say trying to be I've written stuff
you can buy it links in the description
so yes I am a writer
so I'd always have at the very least
that perspective and I like to think
that my critical faculties have refined
my ability to examine all those things
and those thoughts and those feelings
more than they would have been otherwise
but that does ultimately create this
disconnect and this confusion for you
where I will complain about something
where ultimately the root of my
criticism is in the writer's choice
and I'll sometimes you know not even get
people explaining to me like they think
they can talk me down from the opinion
but like even with that thing in
Guardians the Galaxy vol 3 genuine
confusion
where they're like wait
why why did that bother you
and so again part of that might be on a
case-by-case basis not explaining myself
as well as I could or should and I'll
try and be more cogent of that but even
taking that into account because that is
something that I am at least somewhat
aware of
but
it's always going to happen
because I take in media with an ion
writing and an ion critique
and while I like to think that I'm
decent at giving the explanations for my
feelings ultimately sometimes that
perspective is different enough
from the perspective of your average
viewer which again that is not a term of
derision
sometimes I envy the average viewer that
you know they come in just taking it in
basically on its own terms and not even
really considering authorial intent or
that a different decision could have
been made by the author and you don't
again have to think about that well
technically I don't have to I just don't
know how to stop myself from doing it
and it's the critical lens that I have
but I don't have an ultimate conclusion
here
I just
it was becoming one of those things that
and it it there would often be enough
time in between times it would happen
that I wouldn't feel the need to talk
about it but you know again it came up
again
with Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and
I'm like
I need to talk about this I need to just
get my thoughts out there so that in
future if I have this disconnect with
someone in my comments and again like
these aren't mean comments these are
just comments that are not understanding
the perspective I'm coming at this from
and they're addressing a different
problem you know a a logistical
in-universe answer doesn't fix what I
see as a structural or writing problem
or thematic problem
so you know in future I'll probably give
a very brief summary of my thoughts in
case of where this happens and then just
link to this video I'm hoping to save
myself time in responding to Future
comments because when I feel like I'm
not understood I want to be understood
at least when I feel like it's the case
in good faith
um you know and that's part of where the
frustration comes in
I want people to understand what I'm
saying and when they don't there's a
frustration that's partially with the
situation and partially with myself
and
this is me trying to vent some of that
into something vaguely
constructive maybe I don't know if
people are gonna find any use out of
this
but
I uh I had to kind of get it off my
chest
so
what are your thoughts on anything I've
had to say the notion of the critical
lens through which you do something
doilus versus watsonian perspectives do
you think that there are concrete things
I could do to make clearer what it is
I'm criticizing to maybe avoid this or
do you think my assessment of well this
is just going to keep happening no
matter what I do is accurate whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it uh
patreon is how you can help me be able
to continue to do this as my living but
even if you can't help out with that
there are links on the description for
other things that I do
but don't worry too much about that
either
ultimately what I really want you to
remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks my patreon supporters to
make this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Linda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 bernabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalyn Bennett
you can get uh my the bad I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
I don't know